- [Narrator] Clowns.
Some love them.
Lots hate them.
But in the UK, it's a serious business.
(charming accordion music)
- Oh, sorry, just sneezed my nose off.
- Oh, no.
(energetic music)
- [Woman Voiceover] It's a responsibility.
It's for fun as well to do, of course.
- [Narrator] That's Debbie.
- My name's Debbie, and
I'm the Clown Egg Artist.
- [Narrator] She's in charge
of the Clown Egg Registry,
a collection of every single clown's face
in all of the United Kingdom.
- Tradition of the painting
of the eggs was started
first of all as a hobby by Stan Bolt.
It then became a way of
recording and copyrighting
the clown's face, because every
clown's face is different.
Various different artists
then became the Egg Artist,
and I took over six years ago.
- [Narrator] Debbie's job
is to paint onto an egg
the unique makeup of each clown.
- It's nice to have a physical object
that looks like that character.
It's so totally different
to having a photograph.
- [Narrator] The Clown Egg
Registry is a collection
of dozens of eggs that
serves as an official list
of each individual clown's
personality and look.
- When the order comes through for an egg,
the clown will send his application form,
along with some samples of material,
and they send photographs of
themself, different angles.
I start by sketching their
portrait onto the egg,
and then gradually add
color with the paint.
Sometimes it's actual
hair or wool that I would
make into hair to put on, so
it depends on the character,
but they're all there to make you laugh.
Your pose again please.
It's a responsibility
because it is very important
to carry on that tradition.
(light orchestral music)